now to the latest on a black teenager
who was shot after walking up to the
wrong house in Kansas City hundreds of
people rallied yesterday to see Justice
for 16 year old Ralph Laurel the man who
shot him is scheduled to be arraigned on
assault charges today y'all is now
recovering at home and this morning we
are hearing from a neighbor who helped
him after he was wounded Adriana Diaz
has more from Kansas City
at a rally in the heart of Kansas City
Tuesday evening crowd said they've had
enough I have two young Sons two black
sons and this personally hit home what
if that was my son that ring that
doorbell sixteen-year-old Ralph yarl was
shot in the head and then in the arm
last Thursday when his family says he
knocked on the wrong door while trying
to pick up his twin brothers Ralph went
to an address on this road this is
Northeast 115th Street when in fact his
little brothers were just a block away
you can see that next Green Street sign
that's Northeast 115th Terrace just
about a hundred yards away attorney Lee
Merritt represents the family our
biggest concern is that this man never
walks the street again the charges that
he has if successfully convicted will
lead to life imprisonment and that's
enough for us there was blood from the
where he was at all the way up all over
the door zachto else as Ralph came to
his family's front door for help after
the shooting all we hear is a bunch of
banging at her door so then we call
9-1-1 they're like yeah there's a
gunshot on the area unidentified and
we're like just don't answer the door
the police said don't answer the door
the operator the operator told us not to
answer but after seeing Ralph's
condition don't valida's mom went out to
him nobody knows he was hurt he needs to
get help we needed to get him he needs
to be the priority right now Ralph's mom
Cleo nagby told CBS mornings that her
son is recovering but still processing
is Ralph able to communicate Cleo with
you all with no problem he can walk and
talk and all that stuff
he's able to communicate mostly when he
feels like it but mostly he just sits
there and stares and the buckets of
tears just rolls down his eyes you can
see that he's just replaying the
situation over and over again Ralph's
aunt is helping care for him what do you
tell him to try to give him strength
look at all these people that are
pouring love into you buddy
then he goes why are they making such a
big deal
because that's just who he is
he might try to be in the background and
help everybody else
according to the criminal complaint
Lester told police that he was quote
scared to death he says he thought
someone was trying to break in and says
he saw a black male approximately six
feet tall trying to open the storm door
Ralph told police he didn't try to open
the door and Gail Ralph's aunt told us
he is 5'8 and 140 pounds
Adriana was I was wondering that exact
that exact question how tall is he I I'm
so glad you answered that a lot of
people pouring love into Ralph this
morning thank you very much Adriana